26 millions de britanniques ont reçu
leurs premières doses antico vie soit un
adulte sur deux au royaume uni londres
promet d'offrir une injection à toute la
population majeure du pays d'ici fin
juillet le premier ministre britannique
s'est lui-même mise en scène pour
défendre le vaccin d'oxford
astrazeneca vendredi 19 mars boris
johnson a reçu sa première injection de
ce cerrone développer sur le sol anglais
une façon de rassurer après les
suspensions en cascade par précaution de
ce vaccin dans plusieurs pays européens
clairement ce qui nous importe au
royaume uni c'est de poursuivre le
déploiement du programme de vaccination
je pense que nous avons maintenant
vaccinée plus de la moitié des adultes
dans le pays ce qui est une très très
bonne nouvelle sur le continent vous
pouvez malheureusement constaté qu'une
troisième vague est en cours et les
habitants de ce pays ne doivent pas se
faire d'illusions l'expérience nous a
appris que lorsqu'une vague frappe nos
amis elles s'échouent également sur le
coq et je m'attends à ce que nous
ressentions ses effets en temps voulu
c'est pourquoi nous poursuivons notre
programme de vaccination aussi vite que
possible
londres a lancé sa campagne de
vaccination dès le 8 décembre dernier
le royaume uni a été le tout premier
pays au monde à donner son feu vert au
vaccin des laboratoires pfizer bio ntech
puis d'astrazeneca un contrôle de la
pandémie qui tranche avec l'inquiétante
situation que connaissait le pays
il y à renens le premier ministre
britannique avait d'ailleurs été
largement critiquée pour sa gestion au
début de la crise sanitaire
selon son entourage boris johnson a
nommé aujourd'hui avoir pris trop
tardivement les premières mesures de
confinement après avoir opté pour des
règles souples le royaume uni rattrapé
par la pandémie s'était finalement
résolu à changer de stratégie
maurice johnson lui-même avait été
atteint par le court aux navires us il
ya aussi quasiment un an